gli e simone condividiamo tutto nella
vita siamo partner nella vita e nel
lavoro ed è così che vivendo insieme ci
capita di andarci a trovare in un
l'altro uno nello studio dell'altro e di
dire che vanno un paio di spaghetti
oppure di dire ti va di fare due passi
oppure come è successo una volta che
simone è venuto da me e mi ha detto ti
va di fare un'edizione collettiva
dell'amleto di shakespeare
ed è così che da quando abbiamo avuto
quest'idea da quando simone ha avuto
questa idea abbiamo messo da parte le
paste le passeggiate e ci siamo dedicati
a questo progetto che è cresciuto molto
velocemente
che cos'è allora the globe a hamlet
tablet è la prima edizione di una
traduzione popolare è un apparato
critico collettivo che sia mai stata
realizzata di un'opera letteraria ed è
come funziona funziona come tutto il
mondo che traduce annota in molte lingue
l'amleto di shakespeare
per ora le lingue che abbiamo raccolto
sono il francese lo spagnolo
l'italiano l'olandese è anche l'inglese
per la versione della notazione
dell'illustrazione tutti quindi potranno
partecipare è aperta a tutti la
partecipazione in base alle proprie
inclinazioni e propri interessi e per
anche assecondare quello che è un
aspetto educativo fondamentale di questa
di questo grande esperimento abbiamo
raccolto intorno a noi è una serie di
istituzioni e di università in tutto il
mondo e per ora abbiamo raccolto
moltissime in italia abbiamo raccolto
alla sapienza abbiamo raccolto
all'università di utrecht in olanda
abbiamo raccolto a parigi in spagna in
inghilterra istituzioni come la national
operati che drammatica association
insomma tutta una serie di associazioni
che ci aiutano a creare la struttura
portante di questo progetto quali sono
allora le due anime di questo progetto
le sue due matrici
una è una matrice teatrale un altra
matrice tecnologica una è un'anima
umanistica e l'altra è un'anima
scientifica la nostra
la nostra ambizione è quella di riuscire
ad amalgamarli in questo progetto così
come sono amalgamate nel nome del
progetto the global tablet
ruba tablet fa riferimento naturalmente
al globe theatre il teatro fondato da
william shakespeare a londra e dove fu
rappresentato l'amuleto ma fa
riferimento anche alla parola ham ha un
significato particolare la parola ahmed
cioè villaggio quindi global frame light
vuol dire villaggio globale ed è come se
ci fosse un letterale avveramento della
moto scespiriano of the world is a stage
tutto il mondo è teatro perché in
sostanza il logo di global hamlet è
proprio questo rappresenta il globe
theatre che si apre e ingloba in sé il
mondo che si fa mondo e d'altra parte
questa interpretazione era già stata
pensata da shakespeare quando aveva
chiamato il suo teatro globo proprio per
rappresentare che tutto il mondo e
teatro e il mondo è teatrale e ma questa
è anche un questa dimensione collettiva
dell'amleto di shakespeare e non
soltanto nella sua ricreazione attuale
ma già nella sua nell'atto della sua
creazione l'amleto è una delle grandi
opere che possiamo considerare
collettive dell'umanità perché
shakespeare riceve un canovaccio che
risale a una storia che risale
addirittura al meeting di europei e che
passa attraverso moltissime
rielaborazioni e narrazioni una delle
quali per esempio è di tito livio altre
sono gli autori inglesi e francesi e
quando shakespeare la riceve e la
riscrive la rielabora si serve si avvale
della collaborazione degli artisti degli
attori della sua compagnia teatrale
quanto della della figura di amleto
dobbiamo al primo attore che ha
interpretato amleto l'istrionico geniale
richard barbeque che lavora molto con
shakespeare a costruire questo ruolo e
quanto dobbiamo alla tradizione
editoriale dell'amleto che dato che non
esiste una versione manoscritta di
shakespeare dell'amleto come non esiste
in nessuna delle sue opere e tutte le
sue opere sono state trascritte ricevute
da copioni teatrali che sono passati
attraverso correzioni attraverso
revisioni e così via e quanto dobbiamo
addirittura il pubblico che sa
che che ha plaudito magari una scena e
si è annoiato in un'altra così
suggerendo ai suoi autori di rivedere
certe parti del testo
un altro dei motivi particolarmente
importanti per cui abbiamo voluto
scegliere la mito è che l'amleto è
l'opera in cui nasce la razionalità
occidentale non ci sarebbe internet se
non ci fosse ambleto si potrebbe dire
così in modo provocatorio
l'amleto è l'opera che segna la
divisione tra l'età della tecnica che
viene dall uomo e l'età della tecnologia
che viene da se stessa che tecnica per
la tecnica e in amleto alla ragione è
per la ragione la ragione pensa se
stessa ragiona su se stessa oltre che
sul mondo dimostra la sua capacità di
autosufficienza e la sua capacità di
autodistruzione
abbiamo scelto l'amleto perché harold
bloom ha detto una volta che tutti gli
uomini sono
a tutti gli uomini antichi sono figli di
adamo e che tutti gli uomini moderni
sono figli di amleto e quindi ci piace
pensare che traducendo annotando
recitando e quindi interpretando
l'amleto il mondo stia anche scrivendo
la sua genealogia e allora come come si
iscriverà questa opera come verrà
scritta abbiamo visto chi l'ha scriverà
e la scriveranno tutti la potrete
scrivere tutti voi secondo le vostre
inclinazioni le vostre passioni alle
vostre conoscenze non sarà assolutamente
necessario che voi abbiate delle
conoscenze approfondite o accademiche in
ambito shakespeariano in ambito di
letteratura inglese e nemmeno che
conosciate perfeziona perfezione
l'inglese perché ci saranno una serie di
strumenti nel sito che permetteranno di
approfondire e di comprendere più
precisamente come si svolgerà questa
operazione
allora
il
rifaccio vedere un po del sito che non è
ancora online però potrete vedere un po
come come si svolge come come
strutturato
e all'interno del sito voi potrete
aggiungere delle traduzioni e delle
annotazioni
oppure delle illustrazioni le traduzioni
si svolgeranno attraverso una mascherina
che voi potete vedere comparirà qui a un
certo punto è dentro la mascherina sarà
come scrivere dentro una
un blog quando voi mettete una il vostro
nome
e poi mettete il vostro commento
questo commento sarà per esempio la
traduzione che voi vorrete proporre e
verrà proposta a un editor che la
controllerà e che quindi vaglierà la
bontà o la non monta della vostra
proposizione l'editor sarà anche un
traduttore famoso ma non avrà la facoltà
di tradurre lui stesso o di proporre una
notazione lui stesso quello che potrà
fare è mettere insieme parti delle
traduzioni che voi presenterete perché
anche gli errori saranno importantissimi
saranno portatori di valore aggiunto
perché delle volte e dagli errori che
nascono le cose più interessanti e anche
dall'ingenuità o dalle invenzioni che
vengono proposte quindi si potrà fare
una proposta attraverso la traduzione
oppure si potrà proporre una notazione
un commento allora questo commento potrà
essere di vario tipo sempre secondo le
vostre inclinazioni le vostre conoscenze
se avete una passione particolare per la
psicologia potreste analizzare tutti i
meandri più profondi della strana e
scura personalità di amleto il suo
rapporto con il padre rapporto con la
madre conflittuale oppure se avete delle
preferenze in campo giuridico
potreste analizzare come come è avvenuto
il seppellimento di ofelia che era una
suicida e questi commenti li potrete
fare sia in forma scritta in modo
tradizionale che in modo innovativo cioè
mettere dei video mettere delle immagini
mettere delle musiche tutte queste cose
per esempio la musica e il commento alla
musica ci sarà una cosa che ci piace
chiamare la colonna sonora un po di
questa operazione di questo sito e che
sarà la versione sia in inglese
elizabeth jano che in inglese
contemporaneo di tutta la mia età ho
letto dagli attori e quindi potrete
anche commentare questa colonna sonora
con vostre con vostri commenti oppure
potrei potrete sottoporre delle e
illustrazioni fatte da voi non solo
riferendovi a quelle dell'iconografia
classica amletica ma quelle che voi
vorrete proporre e queste verranno messe
al vaglio di altri editor e potrebbero
essere pubblicate poi sul sito e
potrebbero essere pubblicate in una
sezione che si chiama la pinacoteca
perché ci saranno varie sezioni che
costituiranno questo sito nella
pinacoteca ci sarà una carrellata su
tutta quella che sarà che è stata la
storia la storiografia grafica
dell'amleto e quindi vedere come nei
secoli è cambiata la rappresentazione la
raffigurazione di questa storia fino ad
arrivare ad oggi quando ci saranno
appunto le vostre proposte un'altra
sezione importante sarà la genealogia e
nella genealogia ci sarà una carrellata
di nuovo di quelle che sono stati gli
atleti prima di ambleto da tito livio
saxo grammaticus fino arrivare a
shakespeare che alla consegnata poi alla
modernità ai capitoli che sono nel vile
meister o al settimo capitolo
dell'ulysses di joyce fino arrivare ai
giorni nostri quando nel cinema lo
vediamo da moltissime parti è presente
dietro di me ci saranno delle immagini
riassunto in un minuto un po una
carrellata di come presente nel cinema
nella televisione e anche dei cartoni
animati shakespeare perché si arriva
fino al re leone nel re leone che è un
amleto nella giungla in sostanza ci sono
gli sceneggiatori sono anche divertiti a
mettere l'immagine discar il lo zio che
usurpatore del trono che dialoga con con
un teschio che una classica immagini
amletica e quindi tutte queste sezioni
messe insieme
struttureranno la forma e la struttura
portante di quello che questa operazione
che cosa saranno allora gli esiti di
questa operazione quale saranno i
risultati di questo sforzo collettivo in
questa avventura letteraria
internazionale
il primo e più canonico sarà un
installazione cartacea un libro un libro
che sarà
pubblicato da alcuni dei principali
editori internazionali in italia avremo
in italy avremo feltrinelli in francia
avremo
gallimard con il marchio la tab le rond
in spagna anagrama che lo diffonderà
anche in sudamerica in olanda the name e
presto anche un editore inglese il
questo questo libro sarà il tentativo di
realizzare una di realizzare dal basso
un'altissima edizione di amleto quindi
in particolare una traduzione collettiva
che sarà la prima mai realizzata e un
apparato critico collettivo che si
avvarrà dell'eterogeneita dei saperi
della molteplicità dei punti di vista da
cui sarà guardato e riscoperto l'amleto
ma una seconda cosa particolarmente
importante sarà anche un quello che
vogliamo chiamare un programma un
tentativo di trasformare il rapporto tra
gli studenti e i loro testi di studio
gli studenti in qualche modo
contribuiranno a scrivere il loro testo
di studio il testo su cui loro
studieranno o su cui studieranno quegli
studenti che verranno dopo di loro
perché perché verranno invitati a
utilizzare in modo creativo
i testi della critica letteraria
quindi immaginate gli studenti che li
ricevono li leggono e li devono
utilizzare non più semplicemente mandare
a memoria ma utilizzare per tradurre per
annotare l'amleto immaginate anche la
possibilità di questi studenti che per
la prima volta saranno davanti al al
video saranno avanti a internet saranno
anche sui social network si potrà notare
i social network e potranno rispondere
che non stanno perdendo tempo stanno
studiando anche se stanno davanti a
facebook quindi l'idea è quella di
trasformare in modo dinamico in modo
partecipato e diffuso il rapporto che
gli studenti hanno con la tradizione
scritta sembra naturalmente sotto la
supervisione prima dei loro professori e
poi in seconda battuta degli editor
della di global am che controlleranno il
tipo di
cose che saranno proposte ma alla fine
il lago una delle cose più importanti
sarà naturalmente il sito stesso
il sito stesso che ci piace chiamare un
libro vivente un libro vivente è
sostanzialmente un libro che viene
continuamente aggiornato che si
trasforma è un libro che incapace di
contenere il mondo si è aperto al mondo
e viene conti e si trasforma
continuamente il mondo
internet ha reso possibile questa questa
questa idea di opera aperta di opera che
si trasforma continuamente e questo sarà
una delle possibilità importanti del
futuro un nuovo tipo di letteratura e di
libri che saranno continuamente
aggiornati e riscritti dai loro lettori
queen e che in questo modo abbatteranno
la distinzione tra il lettore e l'autore
d'altra parte anche questo è un modo
questa idea di libri viventi hamlet è il
primo di una serie di quelli che
vogliamo chiamare collective classic è
un modo di reinterpretare idea di
cultura la prova cultura sorge nel nel
proprio nel rinascimento intorno al 500
ed è una potentissima metafora cultura
viene dall'idea di coltivazione coltura
della mente coltivare una mente con
pensieri idee testi con tutto quello che
che la può rendere più fertile appunto e
questo è un tentativo attraverso i
colletti classics di una coltivazione
nella mente collettiva delle opere
seminali dell'umanità
in qualche modo questo il libro vivente
è già wikipedia naturalmente ma
wikipedia è diciamo è il libro che ha
mostrato alcune delle potenzialità
importanti della della cultura digitale
se c'è un libro per ogni età della
storia culturale dell'uomo beh allora la
bibbia l'iliade l'odissea sono i libri
della cultura orale della tradizione
orale sono i libri della voce la sigla
pedi francese che nasce nel tempo della
rivoluzione francese è il libro del
tempo della scrittura e wiki pd ha
sicuramente il libro dell'età digitale e
in qualche modo riesce a porre insieme
sintetizzare le due concezioni di libro
che l'hanno preceduta perché quella
della voce quella scrittura perché si
può dire che la scrittura su internet
sia voce scritta voce che rimane
scrittura che si trasforma ecco allora
l'idea di global hamlet è quella di
applicare per la prima volta
l'intelligenza collettiva alla
letteratura e alle arti di creare se
wiki pd ha creato un archivio
collettivo creare in questo caso un
autore collettivo e anche se vogliamo
così dire un attore collettivo amblè
tablet durante il tutta la sua durante
tutta la lauper a vive continuamente sul
palcoscenico e porta sul palcoscenico le
gli altri personaggi della dell'opera
quello che dicevamo letto è che tutti
sono attori e che tutti sono in qualche
modo autori dell'opera che stanno
recitando tutti sono attori tutti hanno
le loro entrate e le loro uscite e
questa è stata la nostra vi ringrazio
della vostra attenzione